[Music]
[Music]
singing getting buzz buzz buzz buzz dude
what are you so angry about
he doesn't seem angry bro he seems safe
does he yeah that music is so intense
but he is wearing bright green that's a
safe color nothing's gonna happen ever
if you just get done with some sort of
marathon he's bright
screaming see to be a marathon man
though you feel me oh no you don't know
if you're crusher runs does he oh yeah
that's true all the time
yeah voice thick uh screamo music hard
to deal with sometimes um I don't know I
don't listen to it for me it's too
intense I got enough screamo music
inside of my brain I got my own screamo
soundtrack going on my head and thread
me [ __ ] nuts yeah it's also way too
violent man scream oh I used to listen
to that uh ska music when I was young we
would go to go to mosh pits you know and
like some band would always start up
like a horn like Skinny Puppy or just
like her you know some weird name like
hurt grandparent or something and they
would have two songs and they would play
them nine times in a row you know mosh
pit it would just be people mosh pit
that's all it was and then somebody
would get hurt and then like I know
yeah and they put yet they put calamine
lotion on you and [ __ ] dragged you out
yeah [ __ ] yeah no it was it was like a
sense of camaraderie and stuff that I
really really did miss about it just
like being a mosh pits and stuff like
that but didn't some [ __ ] always came
through my Hospital was really like
early UFC for some people yeah
and then also was like kind of like a
brotherhood for other people then some
people started training for the mosh pit
[ __ ] people up did like Ray Lewis in
the mosh pit dude what are we doing man
why do you six for 270 pounds we're kids
yeah it's tough do people still mosh I
know is it still a thing oh yeah
where Travis Scott concert they were ma
Travis Colin
like everything oh yeah they're Martian
oh boy
like they make the circle like spring
and then when the song drops they [ __ ]
charge each other do kids are crazy
black kids doing it really they were
black i'ma said the blacks dude I saw
that race is not racist no no I think
he's safely monetizing Blackie's was it
like a safe math I do yes I'm athletic
dude run four four zero
oh you mean it's a Pittsburgh Steelers
Baltimore Ravens is that what you mean
that was the [ __ ] a sicko concert the
Cool Runnings of Maz Pittsburgh Wow yeah
yeah
were they jumping over each other and
[ __ ] oh they were backflips it was crazy
dude any time it's an athletic event and
white people are doing it black we will
let me see take over bro except for
there's some events it's not like that
hockey rock climbing swimming swimming
hockey swimming rock black lava as they
call it
so what else what else
horse UFC John Jones best fighter on
planet Earth
music one last the other night doesn't
matter but black black people passed
though black buddies he owned drugs
though well no he passed the last test
one out of twenty anyway so pass one
other 25% I'm Johnson before that though
you know you're right I mean I don't
know why people dominate though well I
think it's a fair I think that's a sport
where it's Brazilians for a while
dominate white dudes are coming back in
the NBA with a lot of the European
basketball players a little bit really
are black kids are getting softer some
of them you're starting to see mixed
black dudes brah Ben Simmons will never
[ __ ] in my heart hold a candle to
[ __ ] my boy Sam Perkins or Charles oh
oh not even close it's just getting a
little on starkwood run circles around
him two generations you're gonna have
like a guy looks just like Jon start
going with black skin and like both
white John stark hair and it's gonna be
really that's what everyone anyway even
yet yeah you're right the NBA is softest
[ __ ] those Europeans coming over pretty
gang joke itch bad boy bra
probably gonna be Peter shoot I was
talking to Blake Griffin right
about just asking him I said does any
player still smoke cigarettes and all he
and he said he goes man there was a
player that I play with a couple years
ago I can't remember the guys name
he goes and he was a chain smoker and I
think he anybody he was a good player
player he was from Croatia I think and
he goes but at a certain point after the
second season they're like hey you can't
but it'd be crazy cuz you'd be on the
court like dead lobby debug smoke so
yeah playing approach morning smoke as
cigarettes brought those are the real
champions who are those guys who I want
to know a nice one of the sports league
you don't play on drugs bro Lawrence
Taylor okay dude what's that [ __ ] the
receiver who keeps [ __ ] I glare oh no
Michael Irvin was always high
Ricky who played for the Gras Ricky had
no sticks no the Celtics the basketball
player Ricky Adams no Ricky green no
Ricky Henderson had to been on some coca
you know fast he was around the base
thanks sometimes you watch people like
too fast
yeah yeah yeah I think they should
legalize cocaine for some of the games
but you make it fun for the preseason
just the team yeah gram these dogs up
don't agree man let me other PD Oh ped
up bro yeah they should have a PD League
bro they do yeah you got it done
that's it boys Jesus thank you guys Oh
gang man
[Music]
the King nothing
[Music]